deuxième volet de notre page d'été
consacrée à l'excellence à la française
nous ne sommes pas chez un meilleur
ouvrier de france nous sommes chez un
orfèvre claude masanet qui sculptent le
temps il est le gardien des horloges
c'est le reportage que nous vous
proposons philippe roy laurent blanc
c'est une pendule qui a été réparée il
ya très très longtemps très très
longtemps j'ai trouvé une date à
l'intérieur 1883 maintenant mais il faut
vérifier les uns des points d'usure
vérifier les jeux les auteurs qui sont
un petit peu un petit peu détérioré sa
connaissance de l'horlogerie est
encyclopédique
cet ancien compagnon du devoir et
méticuleux organisé précis comme une
horloge suisse
il faut huit ans pour faire un apprenti
acceptable dans notre métier et moi je
me considère toujours à 74,9 en
apprentissage toujours c'est un métier
aux faux mille outils pour pouvoir
arriver à travailler et encore on en
manque des fois nous sommes des fois
obligés d'en fabriquer parce qu'on n'a
pas l'outil qui convient pour faire
telle pièce ou telle pièce dans la
famille de claude mazamet qu en étant
logée de père en fils depuis 1798
napoléon l empire
c'est dire vous réparez dedans c'est
vrai on répare des belles choses
auraient par des vieilles choses on
répare le temps le temps qui a passé
alors on remet en route et vous remettez
à l'heure et remet à leur souvent oui
c'est difficile de remettre le temps à
l'heure ça arrive c'est quand même très
difficile mais on y arrive on y arrive
avec l'expérience on arrive toujours
homme d'expérience claude maçonnique est
désormais le dernier à alger du loir et
cher
j'ai trouvé bon dans le remontoir déjà
quelque chose qui n'allait pas ici sacre
actu je vous ai resserrer les aiguilles
parce qu'elle était beaucoup trop libre
j'ai changé le resort écouter lors du
coup le val d'argent 30 euros c'est la
montre se montre amer grand père c'est
une moto qui l'a achetée à salonique
quand il va dans ma propre durant la
première guerre mondiale parce qu'ils
étaient mal aisé dans la marine on
définit toujours l'horloger avec sa
loupe
il faut toujours avoir sa loupe en
permanence pour regarder les pièces les
petites pièces de prêt kouassi ici c'est
quelque chose de très pratique
c'est la loupe d'horloger c'est alors je
la mets là parce que ça fait nord depuis
ces pratiques
après 60 ans d'activité en comptant les
années d'apprentissage avec son père
claude mazamet a toujours le feu sacré
et ses horloges dans un concert
impromptu lui rendait bien
après ce reportage senneurs de
l'entretien nous allons retrouver notre
invité dans son cadre de vie son lieu de
travail
racontez nous alors là ici c'est mon
poste principal je travaille ici avec
tous mes outils à portée de la main
parce qu'il faut jamais cherché il faut
toujours que l'outil soit voilà suit la
vallasse il avala il faut toujours avoir
ça tout de suite ici bon je répare je
restaure les pendules j'ai mon diplôme
ici que j'ai passé en 1964 à bourges
chez monsieur prély qui était la chambre
des métiers voilà mais votre fille s'est
formé mon fils mathieu qui est horloger
aussi voilà et ça c'est mon contrat
d'apprentissage que mon père a fait le
mois d'octobre 1969 50
ouais ça commence alors ici on a toutes
sortes dans les boîtes toutes sortes de
petites petit outillage voilà vous avez
les machines à régler machine à régler
montre machine à régler les pendules
machines de précision à régler toutes
les pendus hélas là vous avez ici un une
neuchâteloise
une neuchâteloise louis saez un qui va
être en restauration et encore des
pièces d'exception chez vous puis alors
ben on a des bonnes choses en ce moment
nous avons principalement cette chose là
qui est une pendule empire 10 809 c'est
noté à l'intérieur c'est une pièce
magnifique le sujet représentent les
premiers pas de l'enfant avec un cadran
signé duflot à paris très très belle
pendule vous avez aussi également une
pendule empire ici à colonnes vous avez
des pendules fin 19e qui sont plus
courantes
vous avez également ici aussi une
pendule empire qui est d'une très belle
qualité une très belle provenance une
pendule de style napoléon iii bull bon
elle est un petit peu fatigué mais bon
on la laisse dans son jus merci monsieur
marc annexes dans ce tour du
propriétaire
vous l'avez compris notre invité à
intarissable notre périple va se
poursuivre chez une cristallerie d'art